[Musique]
Véronique prince Christian Dufour Michel
sur
je vais vous faire entendre monsieur
Trudeau aujourd'hui sur le chemin Roxane
ensuite on ira rejoindre notre collègue
Romain schrey qui
étudie ça avec minutie depuis des
semaines et des semaines qui va nous
raconter un peu les coulisses qu'il y
avait un bon texte ce matin les
coulisses de la négociation
mais d'abord monsieur Trudeau
le système qu'on avait mis un Roxane
c'était pour faire l'analyse de gens
pour qu'ils puissent rester mais non on
va pas avoir à faire le même niveau de
processus et oui les gens qui traversent
de façon irrégulière en dans une semaine
on va les renvoyer un poisson on va
continuer de regarder ce qui est
nécessaire pour assurer la sécurité de
nos frontières et surtout pour démontrer
qu'on a un système d'immigration qui
fonctionne pour les Canadiens
la question que je crois qu'elle est
n'avait posé monsieur Trudeau la
deuxième partie de la réponse avait
entendu c'est ce qu'il y aura davantage
de ressources de GRC de gens parce que
là ils auront un 14 jours si quelqu'un
traverse il peut entre guillemets se
cacher ou peu importe où pendant 14
jours on ne pourra plus le renvoyer donc
il y a comment tout ça va se jouer tour
de table Michel seoji je commence avec
vous
on en a beaucoup parlé vendredi ensemble
il y a eu une entente finalement c'est
beaucoup plus clair il y a des
conséquences qu'il faut gérer
oui il y a des conséquences qu'il faut
gérer d'abord si toute la frontière
devient poste d'entrée vous avez aussi
dire que il y a des gens qui vont quand
même essayer de rentrer il faut pas
croire que parce que le chemin avec il y
a pas des gens qui vont essayer d'entrer
au Canada illégalement alors ça il va
falloir gérer ça il va falloir gérer la
question des quatre jours c'est plus
compliqué que ça ne me laisse cette
histoire-là c'est pas trop ce que ça que
ça va donner à la fin mais est-ce que
c'est une invitation à se cacher pendant
deux semaines c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut démêler et
d'autre part
est-ce qu'on va vraiment
quels sont les critères à partir
desquels on va retourner des gens ça non
plus c'est pas complètement clair alors
la procédure est à peu près correcte ce
qu'on voit c'est c'est quoi les critères
mais comment ça va être appliqué le
diable
ou du côté américain il y a une dame je
sais pas si vous avez entendu tout à
l'heure qui est qui aide ces gens là
avant qu'il avant qu'il traverse qu'il
ne traversait au Canada qui dit on
aurait aimé savoir un petit deux
semaines parce que nous on n'est pas
tout à fait prêt à ça il y a du vrai
monde quand même qui sont impliqués
Christian mais quand même je vous ai pas
entendu vous étiez pas avec nous
vendredi sur la nouvelle d'abord de
cette fermeture
vous c'est ce que vous réclamiez comme
d'autres depuis un bout de temps là
satisfaction mais je te dis je me suis
trompé parce que moi je prétendais que
s'il y avait une volonté politique on
pouvait fermer le chemin Roxane en deux
semaines mais je pensais pas qu'on
pourrait le faire en deux heures mais
aussi je ne savais pas qu'il y avait un
an qui avait eu une entente surréaliste
en fait entre le gouvernement canadien
et le gouvernement américain sur ce
thème là qui aurait permis s'il y avait
eu réelle volonté politique à Ottawa de
fermer le chemin Roxane beaucoup plus
rapidement et c'est là je vous avoue
qu'après midi peut-être que je me trompe
mes collègues me corrigeants si je me
trompe mais je trouve que c'est odieux
et honteux ça veut dire que tant que
c'était juste un problème québécois
s'intéressait pas vraiment le
gouvernement fédéral il y avait pas de
volonté politique la volonté politique
est arrivée quand il s'est mis à avoir
eu des problèmes à Niagara Falls quand
c'est devenu un problème davantage
canadien et moi je veux dire peut-être
que je suis un mauvais esprit je me
demande s'il y a pas certaines personnes
dans l'entourage monsieur Trudeau qui
déballer québécois qui sont fermés à
l'immigration tout multiplier réalisé
qu'il supporte le chemin et enfin par
rapport au problème dont on nous parle
depuis trois quatre jours parce que du
monde réel sont affectés comme ça on
avait les moyens d'anticiper on est on
avait les moyens de planifier ce midi
j'entendais la ministre québécoise
responsable de ça l'émission de David
qui elle-même apprenait un tas de choses
vous écoutez c'est de responsabilité
mais je pense qu'il faut pas passer trop
vite là-dessus là c'est depuis un an
Ottawa aurait pu le fermer s'il y avait
une volonté politique et la volonté
politique est arrivée quand ça fait que
le reste garder cette ligne là parce que
c'est pour ça que Romain est ici là je
suis pas sûr que c'est tout à fait ça
mais gardez cette règle-là c'est
intéressant comme question Véronique par
ailleurs monsieur Legault le
gouvernement la Gaule su vendredi midi
que ça que c'était conclu madame
Fréchette ah ben on va les entendre
tiens je les ai monsieur Legault madame
Fréchet qui dit que les 15000 en retour
que le Canada dit vouloir accep le
Québec dit nous on en veut pas là on en
veut zéro on écoute pas on revient tout
de suite Véronique
vous avez devant vous un premier du
Québec qui est heureux de savoir que ce
soit Rémi enfin le chemin Roxane va être
fermé là je pense c'est une belle
victoire une très belle victoire pour le
Québec
on demande à ce que c'est 15000
personnes additionnelles soit redirigé
vers d'autres provinces considérantes
notre capacité d'accueil est déjà
atteinte voire dépasser donc voilà c'est
15000 personnes additionnelles il n'y a
pas il y a pas possibilité pour le
Québec
oui je vais demander même des
francophones parce qu'on parle beaucoup
des noms on n'en veut pas des 15 mètres
je vais revenir assumer Véronique sur le
fond le Québec bon monsieur Legault on
l'utilisation du mot victoire
a dit c'est une belle victoire pour le
Québec évidemment le
pas seulement l'expression mais le spin
c'est-à-dire que le fédéral réagit à la
réaction du gouvernement du Québec
d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression qu'ils
veulent surfer sur ce spin là encore
aujourd'hui parce que j'entendais Michel
et un instant qui disait ouais la
mécanique il me semble que beaucoup de
détails qu'on a pas encore c'est vrai
mais quand je demande justement ou à
l'entourage de monsieur Legault est-ce
que ça vous inquiète la mécanique ça a
pas l'air du tout les inquiéter pour
l'instant il continue de dire que c'est
une victoire pour eux puis en fait il y
en avait besoin de se gain là surtout
après la question des transferts en
santé parce que rappelez-vous combien de
fois François Legault avant la campagne
électorale a dit j'ai besoin d'un mandat
phare j'ai besoin d'avoir une grosse
représentation pour après ça aller
devant juste un Trudeau faire des
demandes puis avoir des réponses à mes
demandes mais avec les transferts en
santé il y a pas eu tout ce qu'il
voulait alors il avait besoin de montrer
qu'il a fait un gain et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ils veulent surfer comme
je disais encore une fois sur ce gain là
peut-être que d'ici la fin de la semaine
ils vont exprimer les inquiétudes
concernant la mécanique mais pour
aujourd'hui encore ok alors je reprends
ce que Christian disait se demander dit
votre analyse Christian qui est quand on
regarde la séquence Romains c'est là que
je vous accueille quand on regarde la
séquence dès que ce sujet-là est devenu
pas canadien devenu ontarien aussi on a
l'impression que là la pression avait à
Washington a été plus forte vous
racontez ce matin romain dans votre
texte que depuis un an on avait un
espèce d'accord de principe avec les
Américains pour étendre à tous les
chemins l'accord des tiers des sud de
sorte qu'on pourrait refouler même aux
chemins irréguliers Roxan alors pourquoi
ça a pris autant de temps romain
je reviens Patrice est-ce que vous avez
dit vous avez utilisé le bon terme
accorde et je reviens encore un petit
peu en arrière c'était en décembre 2021
à côté de vous Patrice il y avait juste
un Trudeau et à ce moment-là il avait
dit on va mettre fin moi-même j'étais
allé à roxamraud quelques jours plus tôt
pour faire un sujet sur la réouverture
de la frontière le réseau de passeur les
taxis les chauffeurs de taxis qui
demandaient beaucoup d'argent et les
centaines de personnes qui revenaient et
à ce moment-là j'étais un truc de vous
avez dit bientôt ce sera la fin des
migrations irrégulières ensuite j'ai
fait un reportage quelques semaines plus
tard disons que le gouvernement canadien
avait déjà donné son avis son opinion
gouvernement américain disant vouloir
étendre l'entente et sur l'ensemble de
la frontière ça a été dès le départ
comme l'entend des tiers-payés en 2002
une volonté canadienne il y a eu un
accord de principe qui a été signé
effectivement en mars 2022 et en avril
2022 par le Canada les États-Unis mais
là encore je reviens un petit peu en
arrière à ce moment là on parlait à
peine d'un record à venir au Canada
quand ces discussions mieux les
frontières
viendrontière sud je vais au bousculer
gentiment je sais que je vous aime
beaucoup pourquoi ça s'est pas fait à ce
moment-là en mars 22
et bien tout simplement parce que
c'était une volonté peut-être de
fonctionner de négocier des temps mais
c'était absolument pas une priorité pour
les Américains parce qu'elles sont là
quand on a signé cet accord de principe
là les Américains ont commencé à être
pris par un flux incessant de personnes
on parle de centaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont arrivées sur la
frontière sud donc Joe Biden
souvenez-vous-en il y a encore quelques
mois quelques semaines devaient parler
de ça de d'action à prendre sur la
Fondation donc les américains n'étaient
pas du tout pressés à mettre en accord
ce qu'ils ont signé donc mettre en
accord le protocole finance que c'était
pas une entente qui avait c'était un
protocole de négociation il y avait
beaucoup d'éléments les éléments
sélectionnés notamment les 14 jours ce
qui a longtemps traîné on avait parlé
depuis des mois notamment c'était les
Américains voulaient savoir combien de
temps vous allez attendre avant de nous
renvoyer les gens il fallait se mettre
d'accord sur une date des Américains
vous voulez pas que les Canadiens
puissent envoyer des personnes qui
puissent être retrouvés par exemple six
mois plus tard qui vont faire une
demande d'asile 5 mois 6 mois après leur
arrivée donc de trouver une date il y a
une date de 14 jours c'est encore très
flou tous ces négocié à la dernière
minute finalement quand on se met
d'accord sur les 14 jours se mettent
d'accord également sur l'entrée en
vigueur et ça c'est fait seulement
quelques heures avant l'arrivée de Joe
Biden très bien merci beaucoup merci
Romain restez là parce que mais je
voulais vous entendre pour une chose
parce que
seul
Ottawa seul ne pouvait pas régler ça il
fallait absolument que les Américains
acceptent de rouvrir l'entente des tiers
pays sur
comment ça se fait Patrice qu'on a pas
su qu'une entente avait été signée
comment ça se fait que les journalistes
puis votre journaliste vous dit que
c'était pas une priorité aux États-Unis
c'est ça moi je me demande si tu as une
priorité Ottawa je dois être sûr que
c'est une priorité à toi il y a quand
même arrivé quelque chose il y a un an
là c'est peut-être pas encore finalisé
mais ce qu'il fallait vraiment que ça
prenne un an parce que pour les
Québécois là je me ressemble ça a été
une horreur ça a été un cancer est-ce
qu'il fait est-ce que c'est normal que
ça ait pris un an après la signature de
quelque chose il y a un an comment ça se
fait qu'on l'opposition que s'il y a une
signature
l'enjeu sur les mots là il y a eu une
entente de principe mais il y a pas de
signature parce qu'il était temps qu'il
y a pas d'accord il y a pas d'accord
c'est comme on a fait Michel C qu'est-ce
que la séquence vous dit qu'il a parce
que ce qu'on nous raconte puis romain
l'explique bien dans son texte matin
c'est que Mélanie jolie et ministre
québécois entre autres Mélanie Jolie a
mis tout son poids avec Anthony blinken
pour dire là vous avez besoin de nous
aider on a besoin que ça bouge
effectivement ce dossier là Michel c'est
ce qu'on comprend ça c'est depuis
je vous dirai six mois là
il y a deux choses dans ce dossier là
qui sont en apparence contradictoire
mais qu'ils sont bons d'abord ça prend
deux volontés politiques pour que ça
arrive celle du gouvernement américain
celle du gouvernement canadien le
gouvernement canadien s'est mis de façon
plus sérieuse et a senti des retombées
politiques réelles à partir du moment le
maire de Niagara France a dit Hey moi je
suis capable de faire ça
il dit que le gouvernement canadien n'a
aucune volonté politique non seulement
c'est exagéré mais c'est faux ils ont
essayé une fois que tu compiles un
accord de principe avec un autre
gouvernement le temps de mettre les
modalités sur la table ça peut être long
surtout si ce gouvernement là à chaque
fois semble-t-il disait un problème au
sud pas vraiment un problème alors il
faut comprendre ça aussi c'est bon là je
vais aller à l'autre question romain
merci pour votre on va continuer à vous
suivre
si tu fais ça à la trace romaine
vraiment je suis à la trace ce dossier
là vous souvenez comment il avait il est
à place veut comment il avait suivi
monsieur Legault lors d'une campagne
électorale sur les questions
d'immigration merci Romain je vous donne
congé je reviens à l'autre question et
la question je vous pose vous allez la
trouver bizarre
mais la ministre Fréchette nous dit en
entrevue vendredi le l'ancre est à peine
sèche sur l'entente le Canada pour
fermer waxam avec les Américains s'est
engagés à recevoir 15000 personnes de
manière plus ordonnée les Québec dit
nous on en veut zéro Véronique Christian
Michel est-ce que le Québec peut se
soustraire à jamais à cette pression
migratoire qui est internationale il y a
pas un pays sur la planète qui ne
connaît pas de pression migratoire
Véronique pour cette année en tout cas
Québec considère que oui ils peuvent se
soustraire parce que on avait eu les
chiffres dernièrement c'était 99% des
migrants qu'on avait accueilli dans la
dernière dans la dernière année et déjà
le fédéral avait commencé à transférer
dans d'autres provinces là maintenant du
côté du Québec on se dit ben ça sera aux
autres provinces de faire les pressions
comme nous on a fait mais en ayant qu'il
99% de l'argument béton pour dire Stacy
ok donc pour cette année genre on verra
une autre fois Christian
sur vous avez vu la réponse de Québec
sur le 15 mail
pour la première année je trouve ça se
défend totalement le choix le Québec
beaucoup donné là-dedans on a été
exploité là-dedans là je pense qu'il
faut le rappeler donc ça va tu vois
c'est juste la première année de toute
façon puis rappelons que le Québec est
une des sociétés sur la planète moi je
l'ai dit souvent qu'il reçoit le plus
d'immigrants par rapport à sa population
le plus de réfugiés le plus de toi donc
pour cette année ça va de soi c'est ben
moins que cette année il nous laisse
tranquille le système fédéral que le
fédéral façade job quel risque Canada
fasse peur job même si on parle même si
on parle des signes qui parle français
parce qu'on parle d'Haïtien
à un moment donné c'est ça l'histoire
c'est que il y a pas juste un chiffre il
y a des gens il y a des gens qui ont de
la famille au Québec il y a des gens qui
vont qui parlent déjà français qui est
ces gens-là devraient être admis parce
que c'est c'est une un passage normal
vers le Canada francophone c'est le
Québec
quel gouvernement du Québec dise moi je
ne reconnais aucune responsabilité dans
un corps internationaux puis dans ces
faire là puis on a atteint notre
capacité puis chaque c'est fini c'est un
peu rapide parce qu'il y a des gens
là-dedans encore une fois qui ont de la
famille qui parle français qui serait
parfaitement adapté à venir au Québec
puis à s'intégrer rapidement
ok autre chose je pense qu'on a bien
fait on a fait un bon tour ça va
Christian bon très bien
l'important c'est que le chemin est
fermé mais je vous saoulais amicalement
je vous souligne amicalement Christian
que si vous pensez que c'est la fin des
pressions migratoires au Canada ou au
Québec
je crois que c'est un leurre c'est et ça
soit le chemin Roxane ce que vous
soulignez beaucoup de gens le soulignent
il y avait un déséquilibre évident là
c'est une évidence mais les pressions
migratoires ne font que commencer ne
font que commencer là regardez aussi
aucune naïveté par rapport à ça très
bien non je sais que vous êtes pas né
création de santé Québec là on se dit
cette semaine que Monsieur Dubé joue
gros Véronique parce que là on annonce
que les colonnes du temps vont trembler
dit-il il que de la souplesse dans les
conventions collectives dans les
anciennetés il veut dire au médecin
spécialistes vous allez aller travailler
ici et là il veut que ça marche mieux
création de cet agence santé Québec que
vous voyez un patron dans chaque hôpital
dans chaque institution là il joue gros
faut que ça marche là
il joue gros mais auprès de qui parce
que si vous posez la question à la
population est-ce que ce qui est proposé
ça fait votre affaire les gens tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est des soins qui
fonctionnent par contre vous poser la
question à des associations des
syndicats c'est là où ça va ruer dans
les brancards et ça va devenir une
bataille de l'opinion publique ça c'est
le gros morceau de la CAQ non seulement
pour cette session aussi mais je dirais
même pour le mandat au complet c'est une
réforme on va appeler ça un chat un chat
même si c'est
voldemortes c'est quand même une réforme
puis Christian Dubé et François Legault
au début du mandat dans les sondages
internes la cax se dit sont encore assez
populaires il y a un assez gros capital
de bâti pour perdre des points s'il le
faut c'est le moment ou jamais si on le
fait pas maintenant le fera jamais si
c'est pas eux qui le font personne
pourra le faire c'est un peu la façon
dont il voit les choses quand je dis que
c'est avec les syndicats que la bataille
se dessine je vais essayer de vous faire
ça simple Gaëtan barrette avait éliminé
les agences de santé avec du ça à 34 6
et 6 OK dans ces 34 6 et suisses là il y
a quatre catégories d'emploi avec une
table de négociation syndicale chaque ça
fait 136 à créditation syndicale 136
tables de négociation avec ce projet de
loi là Christian Dubé va faire en sorte
qu'il en est seulement 4 alors qu'est-ce
que vous pensez qui va arriver quand le
maraudage va commencer avec les
syndicats moi le spin qu'on me dit là
c'est que ça se pourrait qu'il y a même
des syndicats qui disparaissent
puisqu'il y en a d'autres qui deviennent
plus gros
une compétition entre les syndicats
voyez-vous quand on dit que le feu va
peut-être prendre à c'est un peu comme
ça mais en bout de ligne la population
va regarder sans se dire mais moi si
c'est plus de soins que je peux avoir le
gouvernement va jouer là-dessus monsieur
Legault et Michel dit donc je pense
c'est une entrée avec la presse la
dernière fois a dit je vais gaspiller du
capital si il faut mais il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose je pense que on est
rendu là Christian et Michel Christian
oui c'est très clair après le désastre
de la pandémie c'est le moment ou jamais
c'est vrai que pour la population la
population compte plus à grand chose
là-dedans je les comprends ils juge aux
résultats mais moi je regardais moi je
suis un peu être même un peu chimique
là-dessus mais je veux dire que je la
trouve impressionnante la réforme prévue
par le ministre du B parce que ça reste
large ça s'attaque à certaines vaches ça
crée aussi ce qui m'intéressait moi
parce que elle est là c'est très très
longtemps je vais t'intéresser à la
réforme Thatcher en Grande-Bretagne dans
le domaine de la santé qui avait été
confirmé par Tony Blair que des choses
qui ressemblent à ça le fait qu'on
distingue le ministère qui va s'occuper
de la planification des politiques et
puis les autres qui vont être dans les
agences mais comme le dit Véronique le
facteur qui va être important c'est les
syndicats est-ce que les syndicats vont
être simplement dans la position
va être sur la défensive est-ce qu'ils
vont continuer une partie du problème ou
est-ce qu'ils vont vouloir sauter dans
le bain peut être une partie de la
solution c'est loin d'être évident pour
les syndicats parce que le gouvernement
est Monsieur Dubé il va fort là-dedans
donc moi je souhaite qu'ils aient que ça
marche j'espère que les syndicats vont
comprendre tout un pays historique qu'on
peut plus constituer comme avant au
Québec on peut plus construire ce qui me
fait penser Michel C à monsieur Bouchard
qui avait créé ce sommet parce qu'il
savait qu'avec les syndicats ça allait
être épique pour le déficit zéro ça a
été épique là mais il a réuni ces
gens-là autour d'une table est-ce que ce
serait pas le moment d'un sommet au
sommet entre les syndicats le Premier
ministre monsieur Dubé pour dire est-ce
qu'on peut s'arranger pour que ça marche
mieux
votre
analysé
l'autre à faire on n'a pas parlé des
médecins que
très spécialiste vont aller travailler
en région je suis pas sûr que ça va
marcher super bien souvenez-vous de la
réforme barrette tout le monde a un
moment donné au tout début tenait la
chance au courage en disant ben écoutez
ça marche pas ça marche pas on va
essayer ça très rapidement ça a été vu
comme un affaire de boldozer et l'appui
populaire s'est retirée à la réforme
et c'est pour ça qu'il s'apprend il se
prend lui-même pour Voldemort les
emplois de prononcer mon nom en
publicité alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a la
même chose peut arriver à Monsieur Dubé
est-ce que au départ on va dire ah c'est
une bonne idée puis il faut amener cette
histoire à plus de flexibilité puis les
médecins aussi parce que simplement le
gros problème c'est aussi mais est-ce
que la pluie publique va rester là quand
le gouvernement va
montrer des dents un peu lui dire hey on
va savoir par là c'est ça qui qui lui
est mis à mal la réforme barrette la
même chose peut arriver une autre fois
bon lui oui
on est capable de faire des réformes
encore au Québec c'est la question qui
se pose là
dessus
j'ai tout le temps pour faire des
réformes et on va parler mercredi
on va on va en reparler mercredi et on
espère avoir le ministre puis je vous
réinviterai pas c'est un sujet important
qui touche les gens ce qu'on peut faire
les choses plus simplement bon ça à
bientôt bonne soirée merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI